tout ça dans un instant et toutes les
images Jean-Luc Mélenchon tiens ils se
sont abandonnés par la communauté juive
qu'il a défendu toute sa vie c'est ce
qu'il a dit est-ce que vous trouvez ça
ind descent petit récap et on en parle
après c'est
parti depuis le 7 octobre dernier
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est sous le feu des
critiques pour ses prises de position
sur le conflit entre Israël et le Hamas
et pour son absence remarquée à la
marche contre
l'antisémitisme l'homme politique est
même accusé par certains d'être
antisémitel M il est antisémi oui mais
dans un entretien accordé à la revue
Orient 21 le leader de la France
insoumise dénonce une polémique affirme
avoir demander très vite un cesser le
feu et déclare aujourd'hui se sentir
abandonné par la communauté juive je me
sens abandonné par ce que j'ai défendu
toute ma vie alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon se
sent abandonné par la communauté juif
qu'il a défendu toute sa vie est ind
descent ma mère juste qui réagi je
t'avais dit Baba qu'ils étaient jaloux
c'est des connards France 2 attend que
je le crois je lui mets un Molard voilà
euh bon ben voilà donc j'espère qu'elle
va pas croiser ma mère voilà qui est
souvent plus nerveuse que moi euh oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe est ça un sens ce
que dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon B non il a le
droit de se défendre il a attaqué à
chaque polémique il s'est défendu même
quand ça a débordé une fois il avait dit
je me suis mal exprimé c'est très rare
qu'il s'excuse il s'est excusé justement
à propos de la communauté juive il y a
quelques années donc il fait de la
politiqueexcuser en fait pardon pass sa
vie à s'excuser en non ah non pas du
tout il s'est excusé une seule fois
moi je trouve je raconte la vérité donc
il a tout à fait le droit de dire qu'il
a combattu tout le temps tous les
racismes l'antisémitisme il assure qu'il
n'a jamais manqué à son devoir même si
on peut lui faire un procès en
antisémitisme c'est normal qu'il se
défende voilà il a Cyr on ne peut pas
lui couper la parole quand même on peut
pas le censurer madame Madame Valérie
l'appareil moi je fais pas de Procé en
antisémitisme voilà en revanche qu'il
induis des choses qui mènent à l'antis
sémitisme ça je peux lui faire le ce
procès-là parce que il emploie de
manière récurrente et répétée des
tropismes antisémites quand il explique
que par exemple pendant les élections de
corbine au législative de corbin Corbin
a perdu les élections à cause du grand
Rabin de Grande-Bretagne et quand il dit
que dans le même poste d'ailleurs je
aller remonter jusqu'en 2019 dans le
même poste il il incrimine le CRIF oou
qu'il dit qu'il dit être d'extrême
droite d'ailleurs même laafp c'est peut
dire le corrige et puis qu'il il parle
de génuflexion devant les zouase
arrogante et et communautariste ça c'est
du vocable dont on sait où ça mène quand
il parle d'Élisabeth borne qu' dont il
dit qu'elle se rallie à un point de vue
étranger quand il parle de yel Bron pivé
qui campe en Israël quand il parle de
Rutel criief évidemment tu es pas bien
là-dessus quand il dit que Zemour
reproduit des scénarios culturels issus
du judaïsme pour expliquer ses idées
d'extrême droite en gros Zemour est
extrême droite parce qu'il
reproduiténar C Val mais oui pardon mais
tout ça fait quand même une sorte de
continuum oui donc après je ne dis pas
qu'il est qu'il est antisémite je dis
qu'il PvE le chemin des antisém je
comprends je comprends et comme toutes
les personnalités enfin comme beaucoup
accusés d'antisémitisme c'est jamais
clair ça qu'il y a des sous-entendus là
il s'excuse qu'à moitié sur un propos et
je trouve qu'à chaque fois qu'il parle
des Juifs et de cette religion il émane
une sorte de malaise de Jean-Luc mchant
il fitie de s'excuser fermement-moi
twister pendant cette séquence je vous
en supplie faites-moi twister faites-moi
twister allez Géraldine fais-moi twister
mais en fait il est dans la rédemption
il cherche à s'acheter une virginité
personnellement je n'y crois pas je vais
pouvoir continuer la la liste absolument
dégueulasse de de Valérie comme ça g tu
je sais pas si tu t'en souviendras a si
tu es devenu amnésique ou ch ah ça
marche pour la
S la marionnette de Macron avec un
écrochu qui rappelle les caricatures
antisémit du 19e et du début du 20e
siècle et puis le pompon alors là cerise
sur le gâteau de deun antisémitisme
immonde quand il a les attentats euh à
Toulouse et à montauan de de Mohamed
Mera nous avons eu droit à un magnifique
tweet vous verrez que dans la dernière
semaine de la campagne présidentielle
vous aurez un grave incident ou un
meurtre ça a été Mera en 2012 ça a été
l'attentat la dernière semaine sur les
Ch disis donc en fait il y a une et et
enfin c'est très long ce tweet là ça
veut dire qu'en fait il ne qualifie pas
les choses il ne dit pas que c'est un
attentat islamiste il ne dit pas les
choses que c'est impossible pour lui de
le dire donc à partir de à partir de ce
moment-là tu vois il jette une ambiguïé
parce que Mohamed Mera il est allé tuer
des Juifs à mon à Toulouse parce qu'ils
étaient juifs voilà et donc ne pas
qualifier ça c'est une faute politique
majeure voilàans parler sans parler de
sa clique là LFI là la Foire Fouille là
avec panneau
avec qui sont juste obsèes aussi avec
toutes leur sorties ces derniers temps
donc voilà donc circuler il y a rien à
voir et moi je crois pas du tout de do
TST les mecs JeanMichel oui g
malheureusement une fois de plus tu tu
défends tes amis et les pas mes amis pas
amisir amis quand je défends mes amis
Disle c'est pas mes amis
e il j
é
pasis pas mon AM arrte pouro sera mon
AM fois quand il était
dans
J si pas mieux celui-là malheureusement
et malheureusement Gill ton am une fois
de plus nous prouve que sa seule
ambition c'est d'être un
dictateur tu veux que je te dis jeanluc
Mélenchon il a vu que ça se passait mal
pour lui en ce moment il s'est dit il
faut que je trouve un
truc politique c'est ce que j'ai dit oui
il le droit c'est pas un hypocrite bien
arrête de
parlerich sur le malheur des autres sur
le dos des autres sur le malheur des
autres il veut se victimiser il veut se
victimiser il fait de nombreuses sorties
qui étaient franchement très limite
vis-à-vis de la communauté de juives et
là maintenant il se passe en c'est lui
la victime maintenant oh je les ai tant
aimé maintenant il me rej fa arrêter
comm ça pass pour une victime quand tu
sur le feu faut pas s'étonner d'être
brûlé donc faut arrêter qu' lu dis le
Calo excuse-mo c'est mous bien sûr c'est
un caliméron en mousse tu as de doigs de
twisté euh oui cardose moi je trouve que
sa sortie elle pue l'opportunisme au
moment de Hanuka c'est
évidemmentana c'est Hanuka ou quoi là
les gars on fait un NA là les gars vous
êtes sympas les mecs
là
excusez-moi toi qui es musulman ce
serait pas le
ramadan RAM j'ai entendu dire que
c'était le ramadan en ce moment
c'est c'est
Leide
laide salut vas-y alors alors vas-y pas
nous de Han je trouve que ça sorti elle
pu l'opportunisme au moment de Hanuka ça
va c'est bon
c'est un petit message qui envoyé à la
communauté juive évidemment mais je
pense que ça ne trompe personne euh
d'abord si il défendait vraiment la
communauté juif de France il aurait
marché contre l'antisémitisme il pas
particip Mar et dans la continuité et
dans la continuité de sa prise de parole
il a dit moi je défends tous les racisés
c'est un terme que je ne supporte pas je
trouve que oui che un terme qui me
dégoûte et particulièrement dans sa
bouche dire les racisés ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire tous ceux qui ne sont
pas blancs bien sûr c'est ça mais c'est
dégueulasse en fait tu vois bien qui est
ce mec ce mec est dégueulasse il joue
avec l'antisémitisme comme il joue avec
le vote des musulmans comme il joue avec
le vote des B lieux c'est dégueulasse
c'est de la politique dégueulasse un
moment donné fa le dire c'est tout voilà
moi ça me dégoûte pa qui était d'accord
avec Gill alors moi de ce que je connais
de Jean-Luc mchon qui est je pense le
politique le plus proche des jeunes ah
ouais de ce que je vois il a toujours
défendu les gens qui sont victimes de
racisme qui il a toujours défendu les
religieux il est malin
ou c'est quoi le message pour
intéressant non mais c'est fou ce
qu'elle dit comment il ou qu'est-ce que
tuas qu'est-ce que tu as ressenti pour
qu'il dise il est proche des jeunes par
rapport aux autres c'est quoi le
ressenti tas fait ressentir quoi non
c'est comment il s'exprime comment il
est beaucoup sur les réseaux comment il
prend parti pour pour les minorités tout
ça fait quoi pour les jeunes bah je sais
pas je me sens proch de lui elle saura
pas vous le dire pour une simple bonne
raison c'est comme tous les dictateurs
ils font des discours qui sont c'est un
très bon orateur il c'est des grands
discours il y avait une sondage qui
était sorti quand il avait fait son son
merveilleux meeting parce est très bon
orateur à Marseille il y avait une foule
énorme sur le vieux port ils avaient
interrogé les G sorties 90 % des gens
étaient conquis mais était incapable de
citer une seule mesure qui avait proposé
mélanch que les gens l'écoutent sont
hypnotisés par lui comme tous les
dictateurs comm
C Castro hypnotis
g un peuah oui alors ça arveé à la
présidés tuis tu fais barrage Jama
d'ailleurs il n'a jamais accepté les
élections il il a toujours dit S
jés les agents de l'État qui veulent
rentrer ils ont le droit de rentrer il
dit je suis la République dictateur
dictateur dictur c'est un dictateur on
va voir ce que pense allez on va voir le
sondage tiens je sens que encore une
fois Gill Verdez va être bien placé oh
là là Gilles Verdez toujours dans
les toujours pareil toujours toujours
dégueulasses vos résultats je suis
désolé vous avez des résultats
dégueulasses
associé Paul une déroute non mais pa pa
c'est pas pareil parce que son argument
argument il est
intéressant Jordan Bardella quand il
était venu ici il disait qu'il était pas
mal sur TikTok mais qu'il était toujours
moins bien que Jean-Luc très fort et
très puissant auprès des jeunes
justement comme évidemment qu'est-ce que
vous vouliez dire non mais rien je suis
concerné par vre encore votre ex non non
non mais voilà on se rends compte que
ENF c'est n'importe quoi tu peux pas
défendre ça g tu peux pas défendre NONAH
non mais tu ne peux pas défendre des
propos et des entendu antisémite qui
sont je défends pas ça bien sûr que si
et ses excuses sont bidons soit tu dis
voilà antisém antisémite c'est son ami
il a droit de défendre ses
amis n pas mon ami vous le savez on va
enchaîner avec cette info qui nous